in the super fast-paced world of gadgets
in tech 12 months is basically an
eternity don't believe me
Facebook live didn't exist 12 months ago
a year ago everybody thought hoverboards
might still be the next big thing and
the only VR you could really get your
hands on was a crappy cardboard headset
clearly 2016 was a big year here are
just a few of the big stories from the
last 12 months the ones will still be
talking about next year and the year
after starting with the fact that this
was the year video became central to our
social networking lives
snaps had a bigger year than anyone it
released the fun spectacles glasses and
firmly cemented itself as a way people
communicate now and it also pushed
Facebook Twitter and others to really
get in on the video game themselves
stories are everywhere live video is on
everyone's minds and snaps riding it all
to an IPO and it's gonna get more money
and more legit while cameras were
becoming even more important to
everything we do online headphone jacks
kind of went out of style a few other
phone makers did it first but when the
iPhone 7 came out with no headphone jack
that was really the first nail in the
coffin now there's a booming industry in
wireless headphones and we're all
starting to ask what happens when there
are fewer ports on every device and then
after that maybe no ports at all here's
what I can tell you you're gonna have to
buy a lot more dongles okay Google what
am I thinking you're thinking if my
Google assistant guesses what I'm
thinking I'm going to freak out then
there's Google assistant which was just
one of a slew of a new kind of tech tech
we talked to that talks back 2016 was
the year everyone bought Amazon echoes
or some other device with Alexa inside
Siri got better and got a lot of new
competition these devices and the
incredible artificial intelligence
inside makes it possible for us to use
the internet without using our hands
that's gonna be more powerful than we
realize all of which is great except for
when it explodes and this year it seemed
kind of like everything was on fire all
the time both metaphorically and
literally the Samsung note 7 for
instance was a great phone until its
battery started exploding the GoPro
karma was a great drone except it's
battery would just die mid-flight
boosted boards had battery problems
people's vapes had battery problems
maybe 2017 will be the year we finally
figured out a better solution for
batteries because 2016 was the year we
pushed the ones we have just a little
bit too far
okay so it was a big year go get some
sleep this holiday season and then come
back buckle up that seat belt in your
self-driving car and things are going to
get even crazier next year